[Music]
on this Thursday night a view from
inside Gaza the Health crisis and total
despair we hear from Doctors Without
Borders there's nothing you can do and
inside Hebron a Westbank City where
thousands of Palestinians live under
Israeli rules if there's an emergency
what do you do nothing die Ontario
revamps the rules on alcohol sales
what's in store when and the trouble
critics fear pinpointing the cause of
severe morning sickness I've never been
in such a weak physical state before how
it's raising hopes of a possible cure
and no assembly required Ikea's answer
to those who were tired of
[Music]
turkey global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us Israel's government is
showing no willingness to change its
strategy in Gaza despite the human
suffering Ing and the international
pressure Israel's defense minister said
today the fighting will last more than
several months and the Prime Minister
vowing it will continue until absolute
Victory the American President Joe Biden
has sent his National Security adviser
back to the region he says he's pressing
Israel to carry out more precise and
surgical attacks the UN Agency for
Palestinian refugees calls Gaza a living
hell the health Ministry run by Hamas
says
18,700 Palestinians have now been killed
there Israel's Siege pushed civilians
South where they were told they'd be
safer Rafa is as far south as they can
get the UN says the population there is
a balloon from 280,000 to well over 1
million people about half of gaza's
population searching for shelter the
lucky ones find space in overc of un
facilities the rest are squeezed into
makeshift camps Crystal ganing has our
top story tonight
it's it's really tough I mean if I if I
move the computer to to my left now and
I show you the
street you will see that the street of
the clinic is strewn with
tents so tents are everywhere in Rapa
the eyes of medical teams in Gaza are
the eyes of the
world so it's like we are speaking now
and then suddenly there's a boom and
after the boom it's like black smoke
that is it I mean lives just vanish here
from one split of a second to the next
the need for Urgent Care is obvious but
people also require help managing
chronic conditions plus all of the
issues related to poor nutrition and
next to no
sanitation is manifested into a lot of
respiratory infections a lot of diarrhea
skin diseases I mean scabies is not
something that will take your life away
but I can assure you it makes it hell
Nicholas papa chisu is the emergency
coordinator for Doctors Without Borders
he says it's not just about what doctors
are seeing now but what could come there
are fears about chera we will be
building another 20 beds capacity in the
parking lot of the
hospital so you see that's the only way
to do this it's you
can't support the exist in system the
existing system has been brought to its
knees you need to try and extend it out
of desperation Aid trucks have been
swarmed and looted there are so many
people with so many needs even Papa
Christo Stu struggled to find blankets
for the new parking lot Clinic it's
incredible how sometimes you
feel restricted by the context then
there's nothing you can do the conflict
leaving helpers feeling
helpless Crystal ganing Global News
London this video is causing outrage and
Israeli soldiers reciting a Jewish
prayer inside a mosque it happened in
Janine in the Israeli occupied West Bank
the Israeli Army says the soldiers have
been removed from Duty and will be
disciplined Ben has been the focus of an
Israeli Army raid the military says 60
people have been arrested and hundreds
of explosive devices and weapons seized
the Palestinian Health Ministry says at
least 12 people have been killed and
dozens of people injured plus a mosque
desecrated Israeli military incursions
into the West Bank are common
Palestinian officials call this latest
one a dangerous escalation and say more
than 270 Palestinians have been killed
in the West Bank since October 7th an
estimated 3.2 million people live in the
West Bank including more than 700,000
Jewish settlers their settlements
considered illegal under international
law have grown as of fences and walls
separating them from Palestinian
Neighbors The Divide is Stark and Hebron
a West Bank City split in two where
thousands of Palestinians live under the
total control of the Israeli military
Danielle hamam Jun explains what that
occupation
means a symbol of Palestinian
nationalism of Palestinian
resistance since 1961 these machines
have been weaving the traditional CIA
used as a scarf or a
headdress the last authentic Factory in
the West Bank has seen a surge in global
demand since the conflict
began but trying to sell them in the
same city they're made can be a
problem the Israeli military has come by
to take them down says b
his shop is in an area called H2 divided
and controlled by the
IDF heon is itself a city of symbols
this ancient complex is sacred to both
Muslims and Jews it's also where a
Jewish settler massacred 29 Muslim men
during prayers in
1994 a few years later the two sides
agreed to divide the city but peace has
always remained fragile
now nearly 40,000 Palestinians live in
H2 moving mostly through check points
they're surrounded by surveillance
cameras and razor
wire separating them from 900 Israeli
settlers considered to be some of the
most extreme in the West Bank according
to human rights
groups the Israeli military protects
them first the closure started 19 while
simultaneously enforcing a strict
lockdown on the Palestinians who live
close to the Heart of the City you can't
come to my house I you know at the
checkpoint they close it uh on the night
uh it's only Sunday Tuesday and uh
Thursday 1 hour in the morning and 1
hour in the evening we are allowed to
pass the checkpoint no visitors no
ambulances no kindergartens no schools
no jobs if there's an emergency what do
you do nothing
die in the old city of Hebron people
have stopped coming and Merchants have
stopped selling there's no point anymore
they say if he's lucky hasham will sell
one or two items a week they trying hard
to empty the city and they manage and
succeed in doing that because a lot of
shopkeepers L this area because they can
do living anymore keeping the shop open
he says is a form of
resistance and the reason it's become so
unbearable just look up there aren't
just shops in the old city of Hebron
there are Palestinian families who live
here there's one Family behind this door
when they come out they'll see the
garbage right above them and upstairs
Israeli
settlers Palestinians have had to build
a fence on top to catch the garbage
Israeli settlers throw down at them in
some cases they live just a few feet
apart no here that that's her
Palestinian Family behind it have a
settl here name Abraham so you got
barbed wire just right there like a s
will stop in a to in a roof through eggs
through rubbish the family here I want
the world to know that Palestinians are
living under aperti under discrimination
no life we we don't have the basics for
our life no enough water no enough
electricity no freedom of movement no uh
freedom of expression we live less than
animals because of the occupation not
because we are not
civilized it's a Tuesday night and Issa
has to cross back into H2 through a
checkpoint before the curfew kicks
in that strict lockdown has been in
place since the conflict began now
global news reached out to a
spokesperson for the Israeli settlers
but our request for an interview was
denied Donner Danielle Hamin in
Jerusalem tonight thanks for suspected
members of Hamas have been arrested in
Germany and the Netherlands accused of
plotting to Target Jewish sites in
Europe prosecutors say the suspects
intended to store weapons in Berlin for
use in a possible attack initial reports
suggest the plot was not very Advanced
and in Denmark three people were also
arrested on suspicion of terrorism
offenses not directly linked to the
German arrests counterterrorism
officials across Europe have warned the
October 7th attacks by Hamas in Israel
and Israel's Siege on Gaza could
increase the risk of
terrorism the European Union has agreed
to open membership talks with Ukraine
the president president of the European
Council calls it a clear signal of Hope
for the Ukrainian people and the
continent this extremely important we
want to support Ukraine it's a very
powerful political signal this a very
powerful political
decision right now though progress in
the war with Russia has stalled and
Western military support for Ukraine is
beginning to fade at the same time the
Russian president's confidence seems to
be rising Eric senson
reports a year ago when the war was
going badly Vladimir Putin canceled his
annual public appearance today he
answered questions for 4 hours
displaying confidence assuring Russians
peace will
come there will be peace when we achieve
our goals said
Putin along the front more than 600,000
Russian troops he said are improving
their positions the reality is little
has changed on the front lines since
last winter through the summer of
Ukraine's counter offensive and until
now going into winter again Russia still
occupies about one sixth of Ukraine's
territory in the
East yet Putin has looked relaxed
telling military leaders this week he
will run for president again in March in
contrast Ukraine's president has been
shuttling furiously from Washington to
Europe to shore up support for his
country late today a political victory
for Ukraine the EU will begin talks for
Ukraine's membership there is no reason
to negotiate membership of Ukraine now
hungary's Hardline leader Victor Orban
was prepared to block negotiations but
later backed off Paving the way for
talks to enlarge the EU I think it's
important that we give a strong message
to uh to our Ukrainian friends first on
Military and financial support and then
on uh on enlargement still support from
the US remains uncertain as Republicans
in the US Congress have blocked more
funding zalinsky definitely uh is uh
feeling the pressure to um increase uh
and and sustain that flow of of uh
weapons this week Moscow struck keev
with more missiles and with war in the
Middle East Ukraine is struggling to
keep Global attention on its fight we're
two years in we're going into the third
year and um you know there is creeping
apathy that's why the eu's Breakthrough
on Ukraine membership is so important
vomir zalinski posted that it's a
victory for Ukraine and for Europe as
his country prepares to defend itself
through another long winter at war with
Russia
Eric senson Global News Toronto it's
going to get easier to buy alcohol in
Ontario up to 8,500 convenience and big
box stores will be eligible to sell some
types of alcohol Premier Doug Ford
promised he'd do this McKenzie gray
explains the changes and why mental
health and addictions experts are
concerned I'm tempted to go back there
crack up one of those but it's a
decision many ontarians have been
thirsting for by no later than January
2026 people in ontar material will be
able to buy beer wine cider and other
ready to drink alcohol beverages like
coolers and selers at their local
convenience
store that ends the near Monopoly the
beer store has had since prohibition on
the sale of large cases across the
province we're actually uh treating
people like like adults and I have all
the confidence in the world and the
people in Ontario but mental health and
addiction Advocates disagree pointing to
alcohol using inreasing with young
Canadians leading to higher cancer rates
if we are going to make these shifts we
have to be really really careful about
how we do it and also we have to be
investing at the same time in prevention
of course they're good kids a theme The
Beer Store played on in a 2014 ACT
alcohol inconvenience stores it's just
not right for our kids corner stores
like this one here in gatau Quebec have
been selling beer for decades and we're
just a few minutes away from downtown
Ottawa so plenty of people cross the
river to come get beer here but if
you're on a budget there's one place
that everyone knows you need to go the
beer King a corner store in Elmer Quebec
is one of the biggest sud sellers in the
whole Province a lot of people come from
everywhere like Kingston Toronto
Ottawa and when people come from Ontario
they load up like this would run us this
is going to run us like 750 bucks for
we're going to get 20 of these and it's
like that at the beer store 1300 so
double these two students hope the
Ontario announcement will increase
competition and lead to similar cheap
Quebec prices it'll be convenient you
know late night you know run out of pops
and you need a couple but just terms of
pricing I guess we'll see the beer store
which is internationally owned will
continue to sell Suds across the
province and be the place where
ontarians take their empties back but
Donna for the first time since 1927
they'll have some real competition okay
McKenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
scientists pinpoint the cause of severe
M sickness coming up what this could
mean for a cure
it's being called a breakthrough in the
quest to uncover what causes some women
to feel so sick during pregnancy
so-called morning sickness can last all
day and in some cases be so bad that
mothers need to be hospitalized Abigail
ban explains what scientists have
discovered Willow Allen is an inuk model
recently featured in Vogue and she's
been sharing her pregnancy on social
media about 3 months straight I never
got out of bed hyperemesis gravidarum a
severe form of nausea and vomiting
believed to affect up to three out of a
100 pregnancies for Allan it meant
constant illness losing 15 PBS and
multiple hospital trips it was really
terrifying it was I've never been in
such a weak physical state before and
just having such little control over
like your life now a study published in
the journal Nature pinpoints the cause
it's all about a hormone produced by the
fetus called gdf5 how much there is and
the mom's sensitivity to it really gives
us a very clear idea of what we should
do to treat and prevent it study author
Steven oah is working on both a
treatment means creating a safe antibody
that won't cross the placenta a cure he
says involves desensitizing mothers to
gdf15 and could come sooner there are
ways of giving pretty safe and available
drugs that we know increase gdf15 met
foran is one of those it actually
doubles your level or doubles or even
trebles your level of gdf15 so we we
were going to do a trial soon we
hope and while the Princess of Wales and
actress Amy Schumer have shed more light
on the
illness um its severity is still not
understood o rahili says in the UK alone
between 1 and 200 wanted pregnancies are
terminated a year dreaming of a big
family one day the study means a lot to
Willow Allen just makes me so emotional
because like I
honestly sorry I honestly thought that
like I might not be able to have
kids she's still gets sick but feels way
better now at 34 weeks Abigail Bean
Global News
Ottawa biases and barriers in healthcare
ahead why November Kelly's family feels
her death could have been
[Music]
vented the parents of an Ontario
indigenous woman who died earlier this
year are speaking out for the first time
about the care she received November
Kelly died of a severe infection her
family says could have been prevented
raising fresh questions about the care
indigenous people receive in Canada's
Health Care System Melissa rgen has been
investigating November's story and
tonight takes us to en igaming First
Nation 5 hours West of Thunder Bay
very
[Music]
beautiful and her life was just ahead of
like so much a year after losing their
daughter Ron and Carrie Kelly are still
holding on to her I have her
sock I keep her sock from this is the
day she came home her name was November
they raised her to become a leader in
her community she was a partner and a
mother of two she was this beautiful
beautiful bright articulate young woman
and um her death is is a tragedy there
there's no other way to put it um we
believe it was unnecessary Witnesses
called it a miracle that November Kelly
survived this crash in October 2022 a
passenger in a car that skitted off a
highway into a lake November got rushed
to thunderbay internal internal bleeding
they said 6 days later she was sent home
but for the next 4 months her mother
says the pain got worse she felt like
her insides were dying that's what she'd
tell me I feel like I'm dying on the
inside multiple visits to doctors in
Fort Francis 100 km South resulted in
little relief she was prescribed uh
Metamucil uh she was also prescribed uh
it's called raboli and it's for you know
stomach you know if you have ulcers or
whatever only her final appointment
returned at diagnosis abdominal
inflammation she was sent home with
medicine for nausea and pain the next
day on a family trip to Winnipeg for a
Jets game November was too sick to leave
the hotel room the father of her two
children went to check on her he started
messaging me her partner Brody can you
come I can't wake up
November there's something wrong with
her I can't get her
up she was rushed to Winnipeg St bonfice
hospital after receiving emergency care
a doctor delivered terrible news she
said okay well unfortunately we were
unable to save her an autopsy revealed
November died from a severe infection
caused by a hole in her bowel suffered
during the crash 4 months earlier the
health authority in Fort Francis tells
Global News an event review is underway
but November Kelly's family says that
sounds disturbingly familiar for the 4
months she was suffering with her
internal
injuries and and the doctors
didn't um probe enough to get to the
bottom of it in 2008 Brian Sinclair died
in a Winnipeg ER waiting room after he'd
been left alone and ignored for 34 hours
an inquest found he died slowly of a
bladder infection rigger mortise setting
in by the time staff tried to help
him in 2020 Joyce ashwan died in a
Quebec hospital after posting a video on
social media been in
showing staff taunting her because she
was indigenous an inquest recommended
Quebec quote recognize and eliminate
systemic racism in healthcare now
another family is grieving and wondering
if their daughter's death could have
been prevented our baby would be here if
they would
have listened to her I do believe and I
feel that she was racially profiled
Melissa Ren Global News ening First
Nation next thank you big this Christmas
Ikea has an idea for
dinner the holidays are the season of
giving and Ikea might have one of the
biggest giveaways this year it is a bit
non-traditional this giant turkey siiz
Swedish meatball serves up to 25 people
you do have to live in the UK to enter
the draw for it 30 of the giant orbs
along with 30 vegan versions will wow
the tables of the lucky winners no
assembly required
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna FZ today is the peak
of the Geminid meteor shower one of the
biggest of the year it's Unique because
unlike most meteor showers which are
caused by comets this one originates
from an asteroid so the meteors appear
brighter and in different colors look
out for it and thanks for watching
bye-bye
[Music]